Jonathan is with us Jonathan sin
Oklahoma
hi Jonathan how are you good how are you
did better than I deserve sir how can I
help
well I want to keep this short well so
currently I'm working a full-time job
hourly me and my girlfriend are planning
on getting married next May
congratulations and thank you so much
and her father said that she was our
they were mentioning about purchasing
our first house like helping us purchase
our first help first house nice and so
my question was should we continue to
keep you know renting or should we you
know take that offer and also have me
personally I have some credit-card debt
I'm not for sure about if she has credit
card debt but I do know she has some
money saved up I'm currently saving my
words in what way is she going to help
you purchase a new home what does that
mean meaning I guess he was going to
help us financially give you the money
to buy the house yes a down payment or
the whole thing probably a down payment
we haven't really fully discussed it yet
but that's what I mean I don't want you
to buy a home with a mortgage until your
debt free and have an emergency fund as
a couple right and so I would delay his
I would delay the wonderful gift that he
is offering I'm not sure how wonderful
it is yet because we don't know what it
is if he is offering to pay cash for a
house and hand you guys the keys with no
mortgage and no payback of any kind well
we can do that any time right no
downside on that but I don't want you
taking a mortgage until your debt free
and you have your emergency fund in
place of course because she's actually
got about to finish school with for
psychiatry and I'm currently pursuing my
career of acting and working a full-time
job
will you stay in Oklahoma after she
finishes her degree that's what we
planned yes okay all right good and so
she's finishing her her master's in
psychiatry or what
our masters yes okay when will that be
completed next January and his upcoming
January Oh before you get married
mm-hmm great and what's her career plans
her career plans is to start her own
practice great and of course my future
plans is to become a full-time actor and
you know either hit TV or movies great
okay good for you well fun sounds fun
yeah just keep working it but no I you
know after you're married would be the
only time we would talk about buying a
house and we wouldn't talk about buying
a house with a mortgage on it until you
are 100% debt-free but both of you and
you've been married a while and you have
your emergency fund in place now if
after you're married he wants to write a
check and hand you the keys to the house
that's a wonderful gift no downside to
that puppy as long as there's no strings
attached and him writing a check and
buying a house and you paying him back
nope that's a mortgage we're not doing
that don't ever do that anyway